Okay, I want to become a professional in the field of naturopathic medicine. Where do I start?
Good question. I want to become a professional in that too. That sounds fun.
Okay, so where would you start? Well, it depends on what you want to do. So, um, you know,
if you want to do car practice, then you just got to go to car practice school. If you want to be
a naturopath that can be licensed in certain states, then you have to go to a four-year
naturopathic school. There are a lot of online courses for naturopathic
information and for learning how to take care of people. There's pros and cons to that.
So, you know, on these holistic health hours and on some of my videos, I've shared some of my
distaste struggles that I have on where, you know, I'm on, I'm not on social media all that much,
but lots of times when I'm on, I'll see videos of corticote naturopaths or some of our even doctors.
So, it's even some people that are even doctors that are shared advice, natural advice that
that I don't think is right. And so, that kind of bothers me sometimes. Like, okay. Was this person,
he's not saying he's a doctor or she's a doctor, but they're natural healing. I don't know, maybe they're
selling natural products. I know I'm not judging, you know, their education, but when they're sharing
things that are wrong, that's, you gotta be careful of that. I don't know. I just feel like
there's, there's huge benefits like learning, you know, physiology and anatomy. So,
before you start learning, you know, some natural healing methods, because
no, and I don't, and there's a balance there too. So, just taking some online naturopathic type
things can be beneficial, because you could help a lot of people and you could help yourself.
So, I'm not saying that there's anything wrong with that, but you do have to temper your education with
constantly learning physiology, because a lot of things that I see videos are like, okay,
one big thing that one of the naturopathic schools teach is that you need to alkalize yourself,
and there's books written, there's books written on these subjects that are totally physiologically
wrong, and that bothers the daylights out of me sometimes, because people get led down to a pathway
that's just incorrect. And that's big in the cancer realm. So, we need to, you need to
alkalize yourself. Cancer can't grow in an alkaline environment. How many times have you heard that
in a natural realm? These are just, they're not true. Cancer, yes, is a highly metabolic state,
where your cells are in rapid replication, as I shared, and it's going to spew out a lot of waste
in doing so, and that's going to be acidic, and it can be kind of a slime layer around the
growing cancer, and you do want to alkalize that and get in that and break that up. But you can't
alkalize that by drinking alkaline water. Put a six, there's even alkaline water machines. There's
alkaline water on the market. You could go in a fancy grocery store and probably buy alkaline water.
People pay exorbit prices for this stuff to drink, you know, pH of nine water. Let's just think
about that from a physiological perspective. It makes no sense. Your stomach is supposed to have a
pH of about two, and you're putting high alkaline water in there. What's going to happen? You think
that alkaline water is now going to go into your small intestine still with a pH of nine, and it's
going to be absorbed as water with a high pH. It doesn't make any sense physiologically. How do you
alkalize something in the first place? Put a bunch of minerals in it. Now it's alkaline. Well,
it's great. What's the stomach have to do with that? The stomach has to acidify it. So you're having to
acidify that alkaline substance that's coming into your body. Well, your stomach does that all the
time. Hopefully if you have proper amount of HCl produced by the stomach cells, then you're going to
acidify that. But you've actually done no good by drinking alkaline water to think, but
your drinking alkaline water is going to alkalize your breast cancer. It just makes no physiological
sense. And I'm trying to teach people through my courses to start thinking, to start understanding
some basic physiology so that you could think through this ago. That's not right. And if you can
get your little physiology spice at this up to catch these things, you're going to be better off
for that. Do the people that sell this stuff know it's a scam? I don't know. Maybe they totally
believe it. And I know there's people out there maybe listening right now and say, no wait,
I was help where I started drinking my alkalized water. It's probably because you started drinking
more water. I don't know. I don't know. But I know that it wasn't because of the alkalinity of the
substance you were drinking. So how do you alkalize the body? Well, first of all, that's not what your
purpose is to do is to alkalize the body. Your purpose is to eat good food to make sure that you're
you're low in the inflammatory scale to investigate whether food that you are eating you already have
antibodies. You don't already have antibodies against this causing inflammation even if it's good food.
And you're trying to heal, you know, what you have? Desis needs to heal. So it's just so how do I get
off on that? We can talk about what education I should seek. Because you can learn a lot of these
things from, you know, schools that are out there. But there's a lot of bad information too.
So it's hard to direct you in the right direction. If you're wanting to go through college and spend
the whole bunch of money and go through a good naturopathic college, that's your best bet. You know,
it's going to take a lot longer. You're looking at eight years of education. You're looking at hundreds
or thousands of dollars of education. That's going to be your best bet. But you can, there's
online naturopathic courses that you could take for a couple thousand dollars as long as you're
willing to really dig and study and learn physiology and learn human anatomy. I think you can learn a
lot of this on your own. So it's just how invested you're going to be and really be good at what you do.
And I think that's the key. Honestly, I've known a lot of doctors and I've taught a lot of doctors
too over the years that, you know, a lot of times we're just there to make money and it's like they're
not really invested and really studying and really going this stuff. So it depends on you and your heart
really. Because I guess you could spend several hundred thousand and eight years of education
to just be as kind of a some part doctor too. So it really depends on you and how willing you're
are to dig into this. I don't have another life. I don't play golf. I don't do anything else.
I guarded and I study. That's about it. I'm not a very fun person to be around.
But, you know, I think you have to be dedicated to what God has called you to. I believe this is
what I call it. I don't do this because I like it. It's half the time I don't. It's because I feel
like I'm called to it. So you just keep studying. You try to keep learning. You can get good metrics.